around an hour before the king's
procession passes by a Sky News crew
captures the moment kushnaker is
arrested one of 20 climate activists on
the mall whose apparent plan was to
reveal their t-shirts and display a
banner but he says they didn't even do
that before he was detained
so here you can see I had my hoodie
fully zipped up so the just stop oil
t-shirt wasn't even visible I hadn't
taken the banner either out of my pocket
he says officers told him he was under
arrest for breach of the piece an NHS
doctor he was held for more than 14
hours before being released under
investigation they later told me that
they had intelligence that there was an
intention to commit criminal offenses I
don't know where such intelligence came
from because they did not present that
as far as I can tell there were no
grounds for the arrest and the only
evidence that they had was the fact that
I was wearing a t-shirt saying just stop
oil which they only could actually see
once they had already decided to arrest
me
supporters of the anti-monarchy group
Republic were among the dozens who were
arrested its head Graham Smith says he
was held for nearly 16 hours
but the culture secretary denied police
went too far what they have to do is
balance the right of people's
the right to protest which is important
in a democracy at the same time as the
right of all those other people to enjoy
what was a fabulous day and and I I
don't know the the instances the
particular instances but I think overall
they managed to get that balance right
the police have also defended their
actions which included using facial
recognition cameras they claimed they'd
received information that some were
determined to disrupt
demonstrators were warned by police that
any disruption here along the procession
route wouldn't be tolerated but
campaigners insist their protests were
peaceful and to not even be given the
chance to express any dissent they say
represents a slide into Sinister
territory at issue controversial new
powers that allow police to crack down
on protests if it's deemed they'll
impede people's day-to-day lives the new
legislation introduces a kind of thought
crime where you might be arrested for
doing something lawful to someone else
because a judge has in the past
identified you as being potentially
a bad protester and that's incredibly
troubling
and the coronation is unlikely to be the
last time we hear this debate Ivor
Bennett Sky News